THE CHAIRMAN CHUCK SAID MITCH
McCONNELL'S POSITION AGAINST THE
MEASURE WON'T AFFECT WHAT
HAPPENS IN MISCOMMITTEE.
TONIGHT WE TAKE YOU TO THE SYRIA
BORDER WITH TURKEY.
YOU WILL HEAR FROM A MAN WHO
SAID HE WAS INJURED IN THAT
RECENT CHEMICAL ATTACK IN SEAR
YO.
-- SYRIA.
BENJAMIN HALL SAID INSPECTORS
ARE STILL NOT GIVEN ACCESS TO
GROUND ZERO.
>> THEY HAVE SANITIZED THE
LOCATIONS OF THE SUSPECTED
ATTACKS AND REMOVE INCRIMINATING
EVIDENCE OF CHEMICAL WEAPONS.
>> THEY CLAIM THAT GUNFIRE KEPT
THE REBELS BACK BUT FOX NEWS
LEARNED THAT THE REBELS WERE
BUSSED OUT OF THE AREA 10 DAYS
AGO.
FOX ALSO LEARNED THAT THE BODIES
OF THOSE WHO DIED IN THE ATTACK
WERE TAKEN FROM THEIR GRAVES BY
THE REGIME.
DOCTORS WHO TREATED THE VICTIMS
HAVE BEEN DETAINED AND
THREATENED IF THEY GIVE
EVIDENCE.
EKE
EK
>> DESPITE THE ATTEMPTS, THE
TRUTH IS EMERGING BIT.
BY BIT WE ARE ABLE TO PAINT A
PICTURE OF WHAT HAPPENED IN THAT
TERRIBLE CHEMICAL WEAPONS ATTACK
IN DUMA.
EVERY DAY EVIDENCE AND WITNESSES
COME ACROSS THE BORDER WALL WITH
MORE HORRIFIC DETAILS.
THIS PERSON CLAIMS TO BE A
SURVIVE.
>> I SAW HUNDRED OF INJURED
BODIES LYING IN THE CORRIDORS.
SOME DYING OF GAS.
OTHERS WE CONVENTIONAL WEAPONS.
WHITE FOAM CAME OUT OF THEIR
MOUTHS AND NOSES.
>> THE PENTAGON ACKNOWLEDGED
THAT STOCK PILES REMAIN.
>> THEY WILL HAVE THE ABILITY TO
CONDUCT LIMITED ATTACKS IN THE
FUTURE.
THEY HAVE TO LOOK OVER THEIR
SHOULDER AND BE WORRIED WE WILL
HAVE THE ABILITY TO STRIKE THEM
AGAIN.
>> SYRIA REBEL LEADERS HAVE
SHOWN GRATITUDE FOR THE STRIKES
BUT HOPE THE U.S. WILL DO MORE.
>> THERE IS AN ENEMY GROWING
STRONG.
THE ALLIANCE OF IRAN AND RUSSIA
REBELS TELL ME THAT THE
AMERICANS TOOK BLOOD AND URINE
SAMPLES FROM SURVIVORS OF THE